die Ergebnisse der Referenten über vier
Regionen in der Ukraine wie bestellt ein
Schein Referendum es ist ein Verbrechen
offiziell hat Russland des Boot Wladimir
Putin bereits in der Nacht die
ukrainischen Regionen saporicia und auch
herrson als unabhängig eingestuft ein
formschrift bevor er die Regionen
einfach annektiert heute wird der in
einer offiziellen Zeremonie damit auch
Präsident der annektierten Region zu
denen auch Johanns und donjes gehören
werden
und hier sind sie die separatistenführer
in Moskau gelandet sie feiern sich und
die bevorstehende Zeremonie mit Vladimir
Putin heute wird der creme-chef in
Moskau feierlich die Annexion der
besetzten Gebiete verkünden und uns dazu
zugeschaltet Paul du bist in der
Ostukraine heute ist der große Tag der
Annexion wir sehen hier Zerstörungen
saporicia wie wird das dort vor Ort
aufgenommen
ja hier fasst man sich nur an den Kopf
darüber was dort in Moskau passiert
nämlich dass diese
sogenannten Separatisten Führer dort
jetzt gelandet sind in Moskau ich kenne
einen von denen Dennis puschillin den
habe ich bereits 2014 in Donalds
kennengelernt und deren Traum damals war
schon immer Wladimir Putin die Hand zu
schütteln und mit Russland gemeinsame
Sache zu machen aber die große Frage ist
vor allem welche Eskalation bedeutet die
Unterschrift Putins die er gestern Nacht
geleistet hat denn Ukraine ist Präsident
würde mir selenski hat klar gesagt das
bedeutet diese Annexion bedeutet dass es
keine Verhandlung mehr geben kann und
das bedeutet gleichzeitig eine
Eskalation des Krieges man geht davon
aus dass wenn diese Annektion diese
illegale Annektion dort in
Moskau offiziell gemacht worden ist das
ist dann eine Art Ultimatum geben könnte
an die ukrainischen Truppen sich von
diesen Gebieten fernzuhalten nicht
weiter anzugreifen aber die Ukraine hat
bereits klar gesagt dass sie das nicht
akzeptieren wird und dann ist die große
Frage welche Waffen wird Putin einsetzen
ist er bereit tatsächlich eine nukleare
Optionen betrachtet sind Putin hat für
heute noch eine Rede angekündigt was
erwartest du
ich erwarte die übliche Propaganda Rede
von Wladimir Putin er wird dort wieder
die absurden Geschichten vom angeblichen
Genozid erzählen das was er schon am
Anfang des Krieges getan hat das
angeblich diese Region ja von der
Ukraine
so angegriffen würden dass der das
Russland keine andere Möglichkeit gebe
er wird die Märchen erzählen dass die
russische Sprache und die russische
Kultur in den vergangenen Jahren dort in
Gefahr gewesen sei und das ist eine
Frage der nationalen Sicherheits
Russlands sei sozusagen diese Gebiete
sich jetzt einzuverleiben und dann das
muss man abwarten gehe ich davon aus
dass er in irgendeiner Form eine
Nachricht auch an die gesamte Welt
richten wird denn die der Propaganda
spricht von Putin hat sich verändert der
sieht sich mittlerweile auch im Krieg
mit der NATO mit dem besten also eine
Nachricht Richtung Westen Richtung
Deutschland womöglich und dann davon
gehen viele aus eine Art Ultimatum
Richtung Ukraine was diese besetzten
diese annektierten Gebiete angeht großes
Thema nach wie vor die Sabotage an den
beiden Gaspipelines wie schätzt du hier
die Lage ein
ich glaube man muss weiter abwarten bis
es definitive Beweise gibt dafür dass
hat ja auch der US-Verteidigungsminister
gestern Nacht gesagt wobei ist eben
vieler Hinweise darauf gibt dass
Russland daran ein großes Interesse
gehabt haben könnte eben hier für
weitere Destabilisierung Unruhe und
Chaos zu sorgen aber ich gehe davon aus
dass die USA Großbritannien mit ihren
Geheimdiensten in den nächsten Tagen
Wochen auch tatsächlich Beweise dann
vorlegen werden können sagt Bild Vize
Paul Ronzheimer herzlichen dank dir für
das Gespräch
[Musik]